le monde de football la france réalise
le carton plein trois matches trois
victoires en éliminatoires cet
après-midi les français ont battu les
danois 2 à 1
solidarité autour du gendarme daniel
nivel dans le coma depuis dimanche les
principaux journaux allemands collecte
des fonds ainsi que ses collègues de la
gendarmerie allemande
huit membres du personnel et de
l'encadrement d'une maison de retraite
de melun en garde à vue il aurait laissé
plusieurs pensionnaires totalement
livrés à eux-mêmes pastille verte pour
votre voiture qui témoignera que vous
n'êtes pas un pollueur
elle arrive au mois de juillet pour 9
millions d'automobilistes dans un
premier temps la saison du tourisme en
montagne débutent les refuges de haute
altitude sont en train d'ouvrir leurs
portes pour accueillir le flot toujours
grandissant des randonneurs de l'été
madame monsieur bonsoir
un sans faute pour l'équipe de france de
football dans ce tour éliminatoire de la
coupe du monde trois matches trois
victoires la dernière cet après midi à
lyon face au danemark 2-1 laurent
frédéric bollée au plan sur une équipe
remaniée et déterminé sur un président
en visite sur un encadrement soudée mais
le tout dans la bonne humeur
oui il y a de la force tranquille dans
cette équipe de france qui obtient dès
la 11e minute un penalty pour cette
faute commise sur david trezeguet le
danemark qui a pourtant battu cinq fois
la france en huit face à face dans le
passé commence bien mal ce match et
c'est l'enfant du pays
youri djorkaeff né à lyon il ya 30 ans
qui transforme de justesse ce coup de
pied de réparation
les bleus qui s'installe alors dans une
domination globale conclue par de bons
gestes comme ici avec la civière
mais attention aux faux rythme à la 42e
minute coup franc pour le danemark les
français se replacent lentement et c'est
reparti et il ya bien faute sur jensen
stupeur à gerland mais l'arbitré italien
est formel et même si les chauves souris
il ya bien encore penalty michael
laudrup
le capitaine ne rate pas l'occasion un
partout à la mi-temps pour la deuxième
période les bleus reviennent avec de
bonnes intentions djorkaeff est toujours
dans les bons coups
c'est une alerte pour le danemark 55e
minute la situation
enfin se débloque le ballon en gros dans
la surface la troisième tentative est la
bonne
honneur à emmanuel petit le joueur
d'arsenal
ça a été plutôt dur mais la victoire est
acquise ouais mais tous les matches
difficiles mais les mais les occasions
sont françaises
déjà un premier temps d'emmener trois
buts à zéro ou trois [ __ ] je crois que
l'équipe française a bien fait son
rythme elle a des possibilités et je
pense qu'on va encore monter en
puissance en fin de match encore une
occasion à noter avec cette superbe
reprise de vire
les danois qui font juste passer un
moment d'angoissé avec ce coup franc
tiré dans les arrêts de jeu martèle s'en
sort bien et avec le sourire
la france a gagné tout le monde est
content on va brûler un marcel desailly
étonnant
saleh se compter à l'avenir
l'avenir c'est dimanche prochain
un huitième de finale à lens en
attendant trois matches trois victoires
neuf buts marqués les bleus réalisent un
sans faute alors yann lavoix vous êtes à
lyon je suppose que la basse et c'est la
fête
ah ben vous l'entendez vous même axelle
red est en concert en ce moment même il
y a vingt mille personnes sur la place
bellecour elle chante l'hymne de la
coupe du monde 98 alors on attend encore
beaucoup d'autres personnes tout le
monde s'est réuni ici pour faire la fête
fêter la victoire française alors il ya
par l'envié vole maintenant même sur ses
accents d'axelle red
comment se présente la suite de la
compétition pour l'équipe de france mais
côté c'est assez simple dimanche ce sera
un huitième de finale c'est un match à
élimination directe se dire qu'il faut
le gagner si on veut espérer jouer les
quarts de finale ça se passera à lens
face à un adversaire que l'on ne
connaîtra que vers 22h15 22h45 ce soir
ce sera le paraguay l'espagne ou la
bulgarie fait votre choix
peut-être le paraguay en tout cas ce que
l'on sait c'est que on peut gagner sans
zidane l'équipe de france peut gagner
sans zidane le groupe france l'a prouvé
aujourd'hui seul et prouver à lui même
et ça c'est très important pour le moral
de la troupe autre chose d'important il
y as depuis cinquante-huit que l'on
n'avait pas gagné les trois matches de
la première phase de la coupe du monde
c'est chose faite cette fois ci et il
est clair que à lens avec un public qui
sera sans doute égal à celui de lyon
la france va nous offrir un très beau
match dimanche vers 16h30
la coupe du monde et peut-être à la
france merci yann en tout cas c'est ce
qui s'appelle être optimiste n'exagérons
rien encore nous ne sommes qu'au tour
préliminaire mais déjà lorsque l'équipe
de france joue au beau milieu de
l'après-midi de nombreux français qui se
trouvent pas en dehors de chez eux
cherchent à se regrouper autour de
postes de télévision qu'ils soient dans
des endroits publics ou encore dans des
magasins spécialisés puis il ya ce que
ça n'intéresse pas du tout mais alors
pas du tout michel mompontet alain
points c'est clair mon chef de service
m'a plu à la bonne
rejoindre les condamnés au travail ceux
qui n'ont pas pu y couper alors que la
france joue il fallait que ça tombe sur
moi sujet ambiance donc dans paris
désert qu'il m'a dit qu'importe je
suivrai le match par procuration il
devait bien avoir un moyen de se
débrouiller pour se tenir au courant
dans ce désert et le score du match les
cieux celle d'aujourd'hui crha valeur
tant pis il faut persévérer à une femme
qui lit l'équipe et doit savoir l ou en
année
vous avez pas pu voir le match quel
match monsieur marc honte écosse
supporter le maroc oui japon
malheureusement bas
maintenant que le maroc était lui
pourtant il y aurait plein de raisons
d'être dehors pendant un match de
l'équipe de france plein de très bonnes
raisons et pas de concurrence chez moi
c'est le match que je voulais voir
direction donc un bistrot et j'ai déjà
raté presque toute la première mi temps
tiens un spécialiste il doit savoir qu'à
faire je le tout pour le tout ce que les
italiens
c'est une équipe qui n'a jamais réussi
assez malin je faisais l'interview et
j'ai raté ce but aussi dans le métro
plus personne ne semble soudain pressé
et tout le monde a une bonne excuse pour
l'école buissonnière vous devriez pas
être au travail assez
en surface les supporters viennent de
ressortir ça doit être fini c'est malin
j'ai rien vu
et plus que les joueurs ce sont les
arbitres qui font parler d'eux
aujourd'hui avec deux erreurs que l'on
peut qualifier de monumentales comme
izia soir à l'occasion des matchs brésil
norvège cameroun chili des erreurs qui
ont valu l'élimination directe du
cameroun et indirects du maroc qui avait
pourtant gagné 3-0 contre l'ecosse et
head on essaie donc qu'à nouveau le
problème du professionnalisme des
arbitres qui est posée alexandre qu'un
les hommes en noir une nouvelle fois sur
la sellette hier soir brésil norvège
larbitre américain siffler un penalty
alors qu'à l'évidence le ralenti le
prouve
il n'y avait pas pau un penalty décisif
le brésil est battu plus grave un but
injuste qui élimine le maroc
un peu plus tôt dans l'après-midi chili
et cameron s'affrontent
larbitre refuse un but le but de la
victoire pour les africains conséquence
le cameroun est éliminé
une élimination injuste ça provoque des
réactions
c'est ahurissant de refuser un but tout
il ya même pas l'ombre d'une fois qu'il
n'y a même pas la main d'ambiguïté alors
que j'aime trop le cependant c'est que
tu es le destin entre les mains mais
situe à la merci d'une erreur c'est vrai
que c'est dommage ne juge pas les armes
x le système qui doit être changé adapté
des arbitres qui nous en ont fait voir
de toutes les couleurs depuis le début
de ce mondial jaune rouge un jour trop
laxiste pour michel platini le lendemain
trop sévère joseph blatter le nouveau
président de la fédération
internationale a décidé de convoquer le
président de la commission d'arbitrage
pourtant interrogé ce matin au cours
d'une conférence de presse
qu'est-ce cooper le porte parole de la
fifa s'est déclarée totalement solidaire
des arbitres des arbitres qui plaide la
bonne foi
en regardant les images évidemment nous
sommes bien obligés de nous rendre à la
réalité que employant plusieurs ralentis
qu'on peut penser que nos joueurs à
simuler ce qui me dérange ce qui me
dérange c'est qu'on fasse évidemment un
procès de l'arbitré était de bonne foi
dans sa décision
une polémique qui alimente le débat sur
la réforme de l'arbitrage
il est clair qu'aujourd'hui le jeu va
trop vite pour un homme seul même
entourée d'assistant sepp blatter et
michel platini fraîchement élus ont
annoncé leur volonté de mener à bien une
telle réforme
reste à espérer que cette idée fera un
carton après la sauvage agression dont a
été victime un gendarme dimanche dernier
à lens de la part d'au moins deux
hooligans allemands en allemagne à un
élan de solidarité s'est organisée pour
venir en aide à la famille de ce
gendarme daniel nivel des collectes par
les grands journaux allemands et par
l'intermédiaire également de leurs
collègues de la gendarmerie allemande
berlin
olivier l'herbe la violence les
policiers allemands connaissent bien les
hooligans sont les néo nazis les
fanatiques ultranationaliste il les
retrouve aux quatre coins du pays pour
des rassemblements qui se terminent
souvent en bataille rangée depuis 1949
23 gendarmes ont perdu la vie dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions l'étoile
verte une association de policiers agit
toujours rapidement pour collecter des
fonds et les verser à la famille les
agents de sécurité
pour daniel nivel une souscription est
lancée
nous sommes très touchés choqué par
cette attaque brutale et inhumaine
on n'a jamais vu ça une telle charge
acharnement c'était plein au film est
calculé une mobilisation générale en
allemagne la salle de rédaction du bild
zeitung est en ébullition ce journal lu
par plus de 10 millions de lecteurs
publie depuis deux jours des photos
chocs des agresseurs est aujourd'hui le
quotidien hors pair 200 mille francs à
l'après midi gendarmes français
nos lecteurs ont réagi très rapidement
très fortement après la publication des
premiers articles sur ces événements
horribles première réaction le choc
la rage la colère et puis tout le monde
a proposé le fait que les médias sont de
l'opinion on apprend ce soir qu'une
majorité d'allemands sont pour le
retrait de leur équipe du mondial demain
à la une sera encore entièrement
consacrée ou de gaz
le formidable élan de solidarité pour le
gendarme français est un geste spontané
de la population allemande
l'image du pays est écornée l'amitié
franco-allemande est sensible fragile
c'est sans doute pourquoi le peuple
allemand condamne avec force les
violences de leurs hooligans et se
mobilisent tendance et puis encore des
gloires du football allemand également
déclaré leur intention de participer à
un match de solidarité en faveur du
gendarme daniel nivel l'émotion
ressentie en allemagne est donc bien
réel comme en témoigne karl heinz
rummenigge ou encore franz beckenbauer
deux des plus célèbres joueurs allemands
des années 70 je crois que c'est une
bonne idée d'organiser un match pour le
policier qui a été blessé
ces hooligans font malheureusement
partie de notre société
c'est une minorité mais elle donne une
très mauvaise image de l'allemagne en
allemagne vous savez tout le monde est
effondrée par ce qui est arrivé à lens
les bêtes c'est terrible d'avoir des
gens comme ça ce ne sont pas des fans de
le football mais des gangsters
vous savez l'allemagne compte 80
millions d'habitants
et ces hooligans ne sont que quelques
dizaines et il donne une très mauvaise
image du pays
c'est pourquoi la police allemande doit
lutter encore plus efficacement contre
la police et la gendarmerie françaises
restent sur le qui-vive avant deux
matches à redouter demain soir allemagne
me rend à montpellier
les supporters allemands sont contrôlés
vous le voyez par la police allemande
dans les voitures qu'ils prennent la
direction de la france ou encore ensuite
dans les gares frontière toujours en
direction de la france et de montpellier
où aura lieu demain soir le match
allemagne iran très important pour
l'équipe d'allemagne et sa qualification
deuxième crainte vendredi colombie
angleterre à lens cette fois-ci ou des
mesures draconiennes ont été prises pour
éviter tout nouveau débordement à
commencer par la fermeture des débits de
boisson pascal tous ces bons à la
location ils sont déjà là et ils ne
boivent pas que du roi les supporters
anglais rencontré à lens aujourd'hui
n'avait rien de hooligans mais le jour
du match angleterre colombie ils seront
privés de lierre comme tout le monde
c'est lui qui l'a décidée daniel cadou
préfet du pas de calais interdit toute
vente d'alcool même dans les bars sur
toute la commune de lens mais pas dans
les villes alentour ce qui me paraît
très important c'est d'interdire la
consommation publique d'alcool de telle
sorte que de petits marins qui aura été
prévoyants qui aura acheté de l'alcool
ailleurs à allier ben avion a calé sur
les ferries à paris d'une saison ne
puisse pas la consommer publiquement
dans les bus de l'ordre et contrairement
aux limonadiers marseillais la semaine
dernière les cafetiers lensois prennent
la chose avec philosophie
même s'ils vont perdre un peu d'argent
la bière et agiraient le
le poste le plus important dans ce
chiffre la paire les derniers jours et
il n'y a pas eu de bagarre chez nous
donc c'est effectivement je suis un
petit peu déçu
bien que bon bah c'est sûr qu'il ya eu
tellement de débordements quand on est
responsable il faut peut-être prendre
certaines mesures qui plaisent pas
comment d'autres commerçants s'étaient
déjà résolu au manque à gagner vendredi
richard n'ouvrira pas abouti je suis
complètement stressé comme pratiquement
tous un waza tous mes commerçants tout
le bas du boulevard sera ville morte
une psychose injustifiée d'après la
préfecture mais lens l'amoureuse du foot
est traumatisée elle n'avait jamais vu
du hooligan avant dimanche dernier
scandale dans une maison de retraite
près de melun en seine-et-marne hui
membre du personnel et de l'encadrement
ont été placés en garde à vue mise en
cause pour mauvais traitement sur
plusieurs des pensionnaires qui était
d'une certaine façon laissé à l'abandon
reportage alban nicosie jack garde un
petit jardin bien propret et bien calme
des personnes âgées dorlotés par le
personnel en blouse blanche toute
l'apparence d'une maison de retraite
plutôt agréable et pourtant les
établissements caravelle seront
provisoirement fermée par décision du
préfet huit membres du personnel sont
placés en garde-à-vue manque d'hygiène
manque de soins d'aliments quinze
pensionnaires sont actuellement
hospitalisés chez comscore aux golfeurs
ces personnes ont été hospitalisées pour
diverses raisons malnutrition
déshydratation mais une partie de ces
personnes se trouvent également avoir
des pathologies dont certaines
relativement grave me dit on a trouvé
des cas de pneumonie des cas d'occlusion
intestinale incident a maltraité enfin
diverses maladies qui sont sérieuses
cette fermeture fait suite à différentes
plaintes des familles les enquêteurs
cherchent désormais à déterminer depuis
combien de temps ces pratiques perdurent
et ils n'étaient parfois même pas
question avait un popotin il faut le
dire aussi parce que on mettait souvent
les gars les couches ça par dessus parce
qu'ils appellent temps il a passé
personnel pour tout ce qu il faut faire
tache et pas tâche définie depuis 1986
l'autorisation d'exploiter une maison de
retraite est accordée par les
départements malgré quelques fois des
avis réservé des commissions sanitaires
les cas de mauvais traitements sont
hélas assez courants pour tenter
d'endiguer les dérapages des dépenses
maladie du début de l'année la ministre
des affaires sociales martine aubry a
reporté une revalorisation de certains
tarifs des dentistes ces derniers
protestent vigoureusement il estime
qu'un engagement officiel a été bafouée
en la circonstance et du côté de la
caisse nationale d'assurance maladie
on ne leur donne pas tort benoît
thevenet jean louis ousset en s'en
prenant aux dentistes martine aubry
risque de mettre à terre une convention
négociée de longue date entre les
syndicats et la caisse nationale
d'assurance maladie
cette convention datée du 31 mai 1997
prévoyait une action de prévention chez
les jeunes cette campagne a été lancée
elle prévoyait également un plafonnement
du prix des prothèses ce qui a été fait
en contrepartie les soins courants
devait être revalorisées et c'est là où
le bât blesse le 1er juillet 97 et le
1er janvier 98 ont eu lieu les premières
revalorisations de petits actes comme le
détartrage le 1er juillet prochain
ce devait être autour des plombages
c'est cette dernière étape que martine
aubry veut reporter au grand dam des
dentistes donc un arrêté n'est pas paru
le gouvernement pour revenir sur cette
décision qui a fait 10 blement été prise
à titre conservatoire
si longtemps sur helmand sinon toutes
les mesures sont envisageables soit avec
toutes les professions de santé s'il le
fallait je pense qu'il y en a même eu
matière à créer quelques conflits choix
avec les caisses soient sans les caisses
en application honoraires unilatéraux
mais ça signifierait l'explosion du
système en reportant la dernière étape
390 des 900 millions de francs que coûte
les revalorisations seraient économisés
martine aubry reproche en fait aux
dentistes une progression de 5,9 pour
cent de leurs honoraires
depuis le début de l'année les dentistes
sont donc les premiers les frais des
mesures fortes prévu pour enrayer les
dépenses de santé
jusqu alors ils avaient été relativement
épargnés contrairement aux médecins les
dentistes n'ont aucune obligation de
résultats en matière de réduction des
dépenses
la pastille verte anti pollution qui
témoigne que votre véhicule est
considéré comme non polluants ou presque
vous sera attribué au début du mois de
juillet prochain
dans quelles conditions et pourquoi
explications un bon signe pour sa
première apparition publique voici la
pastille verte elle ornera votre
pare-brise si votre voiture roule au gaz
à l'électricité ou avec un pot
catalytique
c'est à dire si elle a été mise en
service après le 31 décembre 92 pour une
essence
après le 1er janvier 97 pour un diesel
et si c'est une camionnette après le 1er
octobre 94 en essence et le 1er octobre
98 en diesel
pour compliquer certains constructeurs
ont fabriqué des voitures catalyser
avant ces dates
ces voitures aussi recevront la pastille
verte seulement leurs conducteurs
devront faire attention de garder le
formulaire de réception la pastille
verte arrivera par la poste entre le 10
juillet et le 17 août date de sa mise en
service
ceux qui achètent une voiture ces
temps-ci et n'auront pas leur numéro
d'immatriculation avant le 29 juin
obtiendront leur pastille avec la carte
grise résumons-nous les jours de pics de
pollution pourront circuler les pas si
verte les bonnes plaques
d'immatriculation père les jours pairs
un père les jours impairs les deux roues
le covoiturage les transports en commun
et tous ceux qui bénéficient de
rogations préfectorale une partie de la
ville de nîmes privés d'eau cet après
midi environ 200000 personnes les eaux
de la rivière le gardon pouvait être
pollué on y avaient découvert plusieurs
fûts de produits chimiques provenant
d'un camion qui avait été accidenté et
qui avait perdu une partie de son
chargement dans la rivière ce soit tout
est rentré dans l'ordre il n'y a pas de
risque de pollution
on s'y attendait depuis plusieurs
semaines le président d'edf a présenté
aujourd'hui sa démission edmond
alphandéry des sa place à l'actuel
directeur du cabinet du ministre de la
défense monsieur françois roussely
il y avait du conflit permanent dans
l'air entre le président d'edf
edmond alphandéry et son directeur
général pierre dos reis qui lui aussi
démissionne dominique barrouche rémy
poste edf décapité dans la même journée
on a enregistré la démission de son
directeur général pierre dos reis et de
son président edmond alphandéry c'est la
fin annoncée de mois de l'année terrible
entre les deux hommes
deux personnalités qui s'opposaient
moins sur les grandes orientations que
sur une façon de diriger compris ce que
les médias d'ailleurs on vous appelez
vous même la guerre de la guerre des
chefs
ça paraissait évident qu'il y avait des
dissensions sur sur la forme plus ce que
nous on a appelé sur celui qui mettra en
oeuvre la déréglementation et dans le
pays
sur le fond edmond alphandéry nommé à la
tête d'edf en 1995 n'avait jamais pu
nommer un directeur général de son choix
malgré une tentative en 1996 il s'était
vu imposer pierre dos reis les deux
hommes tirant leur légitimité d'une
nomination conseil des ministres aucun
n'a pu imposer ses vues à l'autre c'est
aujourd'hui françois roussely
le chef de cabinet du ministre de la
défense qui est pressenti pour lui
succéder
on peut quand même peut-être encore
regretté une nouvelle fois que le
gouvernement n'ait pas fait le choix
d'un grand capitaine d'industrie
c'est peut-être aussi là un paradoxe au
moment où l'entreprise doit affronter la
concurrence est de plus en plus sur une
logique industrielle
les nouvelles directions n'a que
quelques mois pour préparer l'entreprise
à la concurrence européenne en février
99 avec le été international un conflit
qui risque de prendre des proportions
alarmantes dans une région oubliée de la
corne de l'afrique
l'ethiopie et son voisin l'erythrée sont
en guerre pour une question de
frontières et il ne s'agit pas d'un
conflit mineur les deux pays mobilise
véritablement et se trouvent aujourd'hui
face à face reportage eric meunier
frontside depuis cinq semaines l'armée
érythréenne occupent la ville
éthiopienne de sa langue bassa et ses
soldats éthiopiens n'attendent plus
qu'une chose l'ordre de reprendre la vie
les multiples initiatives diplomatiques
pour ramener à la raison
ethiopie erythrée jusqu'ici alliés ont
toutes échoué et la trêve informelle et
précaires n'est qu'un effet permettre
aux deux camps de renforcer leur
position dans cette compagnie
les soldats de toutes les copies venu
défendre la province du nord le 10 grâce
à quelques kilomètres de là la ville et
étienne daddy gratte vit au rythme des
camions en montant les miliciens offre
personne ici n'aurait cru un conflit
avec l'erythrée possible les ennemis
d'aujourd'hui était léger midi elle
pendant 17 ans les petits grains ont
combattu aux côtés des erythréens contre
la dictature commune et jusqu'à la
victoire commune en 1991 les premiers
surpris les vétérans dans leur ferme
modèle il tentait d'oublier les
blessures des verts il pensait
development economic forum qui n'a
personne n'aime la guerre surtout pas un
conflit frontalier armes et voilà les
erythréens nous ont attaqué ils nous ont
en veille je pensais qu'il pourrait y
avoir des tensions entre les deux
gouvernements mais pas que cela tourne
comme ça à la guerre nous sommes comme
le métal la montagne
nous sommes comme l'euro sheed
indestructible nous sommes comme le
tigre et éthiopiens en ville la
propagande gouvernementale n'a rien
ajouté un nationalisme à fleur de peau
c'est l'intégrité territoriale de
l'ethiopie qui est en jeu la guerre leur
a déjà pris un fils un autre vient de
partir au front nous ne pouvons pas
rester sans réagir notre pays et au curé
c'est pourquoi nous envoyons à la guerre
un autre enfant a dit graet a déjà été
la cible de raids aériens erythréens
c'est un miracle si la toute nouvelle
usine pharmaceutique est encore debout
cette usine elle doit permettre à
l'ethiopie d'assurer un tiers de ses
besoins en médicaments
du même coup de se passer un peu plus du
voisin érythréen et de ses débouchés
maric derrière le conflit frontalier des
enjeux de suprématie économique
c'est l'explication du gouvernement
éthiopien
ces cinq hommes ils sont incapables de
répondre aux besoins de leurs propres et
que ce peuple peut leur reprocher
portent leurs problèmes ils veulent être
sûrs que les erythréens parlerons de la
guerre plutôt que des problèmes
économiques ce matin quelques tirs
d'artillerie sporadiques sont venues
réveiller a dit gratte il n'annonçait
pas encore la grande offensive
éthiopienne que tout le monde attend ici
dans une action humanitaire médecins du
monde dénonce aujourd'hui la détention
au congo ex-zaïre d'un de ses
représentants
fabrice michalon arrêté au début du mois
de mai et qui est toujours retenu là bas
par les services de renseignement du
nouveau gouvernement de monsieur kabila
découverte peut être capitale en chine
sur l'histoire de l'humanité deux
fossiles d'animaux remontons remontant
pardon à 120 millions d'années portant
des plus permettent de confirmer le lien
entre les dinosaures et les oiseaux bref
les idées des dinosaures qui seraient
donc les ancêtres des oiseaux colonnes
descend du singe c'était déjà dur à
admettre mais que les oiseaux descendent
en loser
voilà qui était franchement inattendue
c'est dans cette région du nord-est de
la chine que des paléontologues
canadiens en ont découvert la preuve
grâce à des fossiles vieux de 120
millions d'années nettement visible le
plumage et le ramage d'impro tard
cotherix reconstituer ici grandeur
nature un drôle d'oiseau dinosaures qui
auraient survécu à la disparition de son
espèce
en se mettant à voler nous avons résolu
le problème de l'origine des oiseaux ils
descendent des dinosaures et en ce sens
on peut dire que les dinosaures sont
encore vivants nos jours malgré ces
plumes le protard copté rixe ne pouvait
pas s'envoler trop lourd en revanche
c'est elle et ses longues pattes lui
permettait de courir plus vite à la
manière des autruches mais ne traitez
pas les autruches de dinosaures ça les
met en colère
un alpiniste france s'est tué hier dans
le massif du mont blanc une chute de 400
mètres sur le versant italien et puis
aujourd'hui la piste tchèque cette
fois-ci mort à la suite d'une chute dans
une crevasse dans le massif des écrins
la montagne qui s'apprête à recevoir le
flot de ces alpinistes et randonneurs
d'été actuellement en savoie tous les
refuges de haute altitude sont en train
de rouvrir leurs portes une opération
délicate des tonnes de vivres à monter
vers les sommets
virginie fichés et thiery cible le
soleil est déjà haut l'hélicoptère est
en retard les derniers paquets d'eau 6,5
tonnes de vivres et de matériel à monter
à 2500 mètres d'altitude françois
pouille et a tout prévu
là où il faudra tenir trois mois ça va
du bois au concert vos boissons le pain
qui se gardent longtemps et puis voilà
ensuite ce sera montée à 12,2 à dos de
cheval pour tout ce qui est fait comme
chaque été depuis cinq ans françois le
gardien va rejoindre son refuge un
domaine isolé à deux heures de marche de
la vallée à 2h surtout de gabriel et sa
maman je suis ravie quand ils s'en vont
d'abord dossiers traités ni de la
dernière semaine
quand il peut parler car ton et d'esprit
c'est tout ça
donc non tu as on va bientôt monter on
attend les fans d'école et tu remontes
rejoindre au creux du parc national de
la vanoise la longue hibernation du
refuge touche à sa fin mais la morte
saison et ses ravisseurs ont laissé des
traces le ménage ce sera pour plus tard
la priorité absolue aujourd'hui c'est de
réceptionner puis de ranger toutes les
réserves et il faut faire vite car les
minutes d'hélicoptère cher
saluant bientôt françois se transformera
en gestionnaire cuisinier agent
d'entretien bref en parfaite ménagère
bientôt aussi les copains roi
descendront dans la vallée je crois que
si on a envie d'être gardien de refuge
en on doit aimer la solitude un peu
sinon c'est pas possible
mais déjà le pas des premiers
randonneurs brise cette cellule sud à
peine entamées on est content après de
revoir des gens de voir déjà arrivé de
leur expliquer ce qu'on ressent ce qui
peut voir ici
les conseillers se sympa ça jusqu'en
septembre plus d'un millier de marcheurs
passeront une nuit chez françois et
lorsque les 40 une place du refus nous
sont au fond c'est la solitude n'est
plus qu'un souvenir pour le gardien
cultive jalousement dans son jardin
secret
l'avion fut hachée c'est une vie où tout
le monde doit faire attention à tout le
monde
c'est un petit peu une vie comme sur un
bateau on compare souvent des deux
d'ailleurs et à partir du moment où on
travaille là où on vit là bas on le sait
en fait attention à ça ça se passe bien
équipage d'un navire blotti au fond du
monde françois et ses deux employés sont
désormais prêts à attendre que l'automne
vient chat il y voit la solitude des
sommets la coupe du monde de football
l'arabie saoudite et l'afrique du sud
ont fait match nul cet après midi à
bordeaux
deux parcs où les deux pays sont d'ores
et déjà éliminés de la compétition il
nous est donc pour l'honneur dans leur
groupe c la france et le danemark qui
sont qualifiés pour les huitièmes de
finale
voilà succession de penalty cet après
midi à bordeaux beaucoup moins grave
heureusement que le phénomène hooligans
les services spécialisés de la
répression des fraudes surveille
attentivement autour des stades toutes
sortes de revendeurs ambulants vêtements
et produits contrefaits ou encore
sandwich avariée plutôt que variés
thibault de barbeyrac blaise grenier
cet après midi comme chaque jour de
match à lyon il ya eu des dizaines de
contrôles comme celui ci cible
privilégiée des inspecteurs de la
répression des fraudes les marchands
ambulants
tout ici doit être à une température de
4 degrés ceux ci sont 22 8 degrés là si
vous êtes beaucoup trop élevé donc on va
aller retirer de la consommation et puis
un procès-verbal dressé amendes
encourues dix mille francs c'est
dissuasif la preuve cette semaine la
répression des fraudes a saisi six fois
moins d'aliments impropres à la
consommation que lors de la première
semaine de la coupe du monde
bonjour direction dans la pression des
fraudes de lyon l'autre travail des
inspecteurs c'est la chasse à la
contrefaçon et aux vendeurs à la
sauvette pour s'installer dans la rue il
faut une autorisation de la mairie
contre la promesse de reprendre tout de
suite le train pour l'italie ce vendeur
ne recevra qu'un avertissement pour les
inspecteurs ce ne sont que de petites
prises mais un travail indispensable
il y en a qui payent leurs charges et
notre team au pays tant par conséquent
la concurrence loyale c'est celle
effectivement qui consiste à ce que tout
le monde puisse travailler dans le droit
voilà le logo officiel
évidemment les inspecteurs ne font pas
que des heureux mais leur travail semble
porter ses fruits
le nombre d'infractions ne cesse de
diminuer depuis le début de la
compétition moins d'infractions
c'est sans doute plus de bons souvenirs
pour les supporters étrangers
le football passion partagée par
beaucoup et peut-être plus encore parce
qu'ils se retrouvent un jour
privé de la vue ne plus voir ne les
empêche pas de suivre les exploits des
stars du mondial et même pour certains
de jouer eux mêmes au football
christophe duchiron fédé le coeur de
julien bat au rythme de la musique et du
ballon
c'est un coeur énorme plein d'envié de
volonté sinon dans la vie de tous les
jours
julien marche à son rythme pas un rythme
de croisière
un rythme de moder
chaque lundi et chaque vendredi julien
et ses copains s'entraînent ils ne
poussent pas le ballon il joue au foot
ou plutôt cécifoot pour être précis le
cécifoot qui permettent à chacun de se
ranger cas et zidane trezeguet six
joueurs 5 me voyant et un gardien de but
qui voit un sac autour du ballon sur le
repérer le cécifoot c'est d'abord une
affaire de soi maintenant que j'ai plus
la vue j'utilise énormément les oreilles
donc gérer que je vois avec mes oreilles
mais
quand j'ai la balle au pied j'ai
quasiment les mêmes sensations qu'avant
l'institut national des jeunes aveugles
à paris ici julien étudiait la
musicologie
aujourd'hui il enseigne la musique
solfège piano guitare trompette il signe
au moment où il a perdu définitivement
la vue il avait 18 ans
ce jour-là en cours il est riche en sons
française enfin pas pour tout le monde
car comme dans toutes les classes il y
en a souvent un qui ne suis pas un élève
essayé d'écouter un match de coupe du
monde à la radio il essayait de faire un
petit peu discret mais bon mangement à
des contrées bon je peux pas leur en
vouloir quand j'étais à l'école à
pareille époque de coupe du monde je
voulais aussi entendre les résultats
donc je comprends que isidro et
malvoyants ils regardent le match pour
lui pour julien il lui expliquer phase
de jeu
donc rien mais bancaire il n'y avait pas
la puissance en fait là bas c'était
france arabie saoudite la semaine
dernière avec ou sans images un match à
lviv le score 4 à 0 pour les bleus
bilan analyses et commentaires zidane ne
pèsent pas ce moment autant qu'il le
devrait sous les matches donc si le
meneur et un petit peu en baisse de
forme
le jeu s'en ressent tout de suite
un verbe haut est un peu triste julien
qui aime le foot et les notes de musique
guy lacombe du monde à sa manière avec
ses images à lui dès son plein la tête
sa trompette au coeur de la nuit une
lumière parmi les lumières de la ville
toi jane moi tarzan celle qui fut jane
la compagne de tarzan lorsque celui ci
s'appelle de nivesse muller vient de
mourir aux états unis à l'âge de 87 ans
maureen o'sullivan qui avait quitté le
monde du cinéma pour donner naissance à
une fille qui allait devenir mia farrow
parents qui ressort actuellement sur nos
écrans
c'est la 18e production des aventures de
tarzan depuis 1934
stéphane haumant lui tarzan elle
jane le couple a fait rêver des
générations d'enfants
les adultes eux été choqué dans les
années 30 par les tenues légères de la
belle aux côtés de johnny weissmuller le
plus mythique des tarzan
maureen o'sullivan tourna les six films
qui firent sa gloire jean le rôle de sa
vie même si l'on interprète à plusieurs
dizaines d'autres à l'écran maureen
o'sullivan et l ingénu idéal à la fin
des années 40
elle se retire pour se consacrer à ses
enfants come back dans les années 80
avec coppola ou dit allen ici elle joue
avec sa propre fille mia farrow c'était
à l'américaine était d'origine
irlandaise elle disparaît à 87 ans d'une
crise cardiaque
coïncidence une nouvelle version des
aventures de l'homme de la jungle sort
aujourd'hui sur les écrans un scénario
sans surprise mais qui ravira les
enfants
en 80 ans et dix huit interprètes le
mythe de tarzan au cinéma n'a pas
vieilli même pour les acteurs l'occasion
de retomber en enfance je devais
m'accrocher année and me balancer en
attraper une eau c'était vraiment
rigolade bord la vie dans la jungle
jane vous rendez compte
j'ai grandi avec ces dommages le xxème
siècle de salut dans cette nouvelle
production maureen o'sullivan johnny
weissmuller et leurs animaux en
carton-pâte semble bien loin même ça
rend l'homme singe est entrée dans la
modernité a connu la gloire auprès du
grand public avec le film d'étienne
chatiliez tatie danielle
elle était petit daniel si la chaîne
tonnes fêté hier soir ses 80 ans dont
cinquante ans de théâtre sur les
planches du théâtre du palais royal à
paris où elle célébrait en même temps la
350e représentation de la pièce le mal
de mer entouré de ses amis de ses élèves
car ce sera d'ailleurs le dernier
chiffre elle a également enseigné la
comédie pendant 30 ans caroline laudrin
l'idée d'art s'ils achètent pour ma 80
ans
mais c'est aussi l'anniversaire de tatie
danielle ses partenaires ses anciens
élèves sont venus fêter la grande dame
car avant de prendre les traits d'une
grand mère odieuse t-il à shelton à 50
ans de théâtre derrière elle n'est pas
suivie une semaine pour trouver la tenue
je me retrouve beaucoup de gens qui sont
venus voir en tournée en province même
un pari qui sont venus voir tatie
danielle quelque part même pas de 6 à
shelton soyons modestes même pas sa une
et voir tatie danielle
ils ont découvert ionesco le mal de mer
tandis que c'est plus personnel
nous venons il ya là comme un un trop
plate est maintenant trop nous en
attente force à sortir mais je suis dit
qu'il fallait que j'aille par un
professionnel de les groupes pour que je
me vide
j'étais jeune et vous verrez dans
d'autres photos palette du tout et puis
je j'avais un grand plaisir à jouer les
compositions et il ya celle qu'elle a
toujours cru dans un théâtre
d'avant-garde interprètes fétiches de
ionesco
elle joue aussi aux divers tibet quête
tout ce savoir à l'attenté de le
partager pendant trente ans avec ses
élèves par milieu les turbulents clavier
jugnot blanc mais redoutent une énergie
farouche pour arriver à nous faire
sortir des trucs qu'on n'arrivait pas à
nous aider à trouver la vérité est
toujours la même et où on a vu chaque
soir elle vient se ressourcer là au
théâtre avec le public ça du tout remis
de projets un joli pied de nez aux
années qui passent voilà juste avant de
quitter de rappel des principaux titres
de l'actualité de ce mercredi d'avoir la
coupe du monde football la france
réalisant que le carton plein trois
matches trois victoires en éliminatoires
cet après-midi les français ont battu
les danois 2 1
il en sourit pas si verte pour votre
voiture qui témoignera que vous n'êtes
pas un pollueur
elle arrive au mois de juillet pour 9
millions d'automobilistes dans un
premier temps elle sera généralisé à
toute la france
dans un instant la météo nathalie
rihouet je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée sur notre chaîne
au revoir
non